No Are you
[Silence]
happy?
Alhamdulillah.
Continuing in
the book of fasting therein the chapter
regarding the exemptions and the types
of exempted
people individuals from the obligation
of fasting.
Yesterday morning we discussed
the breastfeeding
and the pregnant
pregnant woman breastfeeding woman and
we discussed the recourse
for them breaking their fast. A pregnant
woman and a breastfeeding woman have an
allowance
to break their fast. Whether it is
because they fear for their child or
because it is difficult for them or
because they fear for the quality of
their milk whatever it is.
Now we want to discuss another type of
person who is not ill. It's not
necessarily an illness remember but it
runs in the same vein of illness.
Meaning it has the same parameters. It
has similar circumstances
and that is a person who is very old
age right this is not an illness by any
means as a matter of fact it in many in
many ways is a blessing however a person
who has reached an age where fasting is
possible
but difficult
they have an allowance to break their
fast indefinitely.
Now, what do we mean by it's possible
but it's difficult?
Remember
all of the
guidelines of fasting
is all anchored Allah anchored all of
those rulings of fasting in one part of
a verse. Do you remember what we
mentioned yesterday?
So he mentions fasting. He mentions who
it's obligated upon. He mentions the
month. He mentions the reason behind
fasting. It is to earn and gain tawa.
Then he anchors all of this at the end.
He says,
"Allah desires
and intends and wills
ease for you and does not will
hardship."
Now also
in the Arabic language is
difficulty that is outside the norm.
Right? It's not something that a person
would encounter on a normal day in a
normal set of circumstances.
When we say fasting is supposed to be
easy on a person and not difficult, does
that mean that fasting is just a breeze?
No. There may be instances where a
person is positively uncomfortable.
As a matter of fact,
the hallmark of fasting is thirst. Isn't
that the case? to the point that
the Arabs named the month of Ramadan.
It comes from Ramb which is the very hot
sand of the desert, right? Because it
conjures images of difficulty and
thirst. What is the name of the gate of
paradise
for fasting
which comes from which root word do
we remember
which is to quench one's thirst. So it's
named after the most prominent aspect of
fasting. When fasting comes to mind
usually it's thirst that is what people
encounter the most have such a difficult
time with. Now
there's a difference between
which is hardship and discomfort.
Discomfort
is part of fasting.
Hardship is not a part of fasting
because Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells
us
ease
and he does not will intend desire
difficulty for you. Difficulty and
discomfort are two very different
things. Discomfort comes with fasting.
Difficulty does not. And so difficulty,
how can we quantify it? It's quantified
as that which is outside of the norm.
If we had a hundred people fasting, if
we had a thousand people fasting,
they're all going to have a pretty
normalized experience. Correct? But then
we've got one guy who is so
so uncomfortable that we can't even
call it discomfort anymore. Now we're
calling it pain
or the person is
in such difficulty due to his fasting
that he cannot function properly. The
person is in such difficulty that they
are unable to function adequately in
their day-to-day life not because of
some discomfort but because of
difficulty that is outside of the
spectrum of normaly.
This here is where a person is given an
allowance to fast. Anything that takes
you out of that norm, they have the
allowance to break their fast. Correct.
So, who falls into that? A traveler.
They're outside of their normal
circumstances, aren't they? Okay. A
person who is ill.
a a woman who is breastfeeding, a
woman who is pregnant,
a very old man or an old woman, maybe
not even very old, just to the point
that they are outside of the scope of
normal discomfort. Now it is difficult.
Now it is
now it is and that is the antithesis of
what Allah desires for us. Correct?
Therefore, a person who is able to fast,
they are old and due to old age, they
are able to fast,
but it is not uncomfortable. It is
difficult.
This person has the allowance to what?
To break their fast.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
This is in
verse number 184. The same verses
regarding the rulings of fasting in
surah Bakar.
Now notice Allah says in this verse that
which translates to and upon those who
are able to fast
meaning but do not
is a fya
an expeation
of feeding
a poor person. Okay, let's unpack this
because fasting went through stages in
its legislation.
It wasn't just fast for Ramadan and
that's where it started. No, no. Fasting
had different parameters at the
beginning because an entire ummah now is
is beginning to adopt this new
yearly thing. And so it went through
stages.
The first stage
was that it was highly encouraged to
fast the day of the day of Ashw.
After that it became obligatory to fast
ash.
After that Ramadan became obligatory and
ashw became preferred. Okay.
But at the beginning when Ramadan was
first obligated, which year was Ramadan
obligated? Anyone know?
Which year after Hijra
which year was the battle of Buddh?
Huh? The second year, right? The second
year. And we know that the prophet
started to fast
the first year after hij
the month of Ramadan there was fasting
and they broke their fast for the
occasion of war and travel.
So Ramadan was obligated in the second
year after hij.
However, when it was obligated,
it was optional.
What do you mean optional? Optional in
the following way.
You could do one of two things. You
could either fast
or you could feed a poor person for
every day that you do not fast. This was
for everybody. Young, old, free, slave,
rich, poor, male, female, traveling,
resident, ill, , etc.
This was the first phase. So you had
young men, young women, they would
choose not to fast and they would feed a
poor person for every day that they
missed.
This went on until Allah sent down the
second verse of surah Bakar verse number
185.
He said
[Silence]
and so with this it became obligatory to
fast and not fasting was an exception.
Now you couldn't choose to either feed a
poor person or
or fast. Now everyone who is able had
to fast.
So what about and and this verse that we
read verse 184 this was revealed in the
first of those two phases.
And those who are able to fast but do
not upon them is an expeation of feeding
a poor person.
The next year rolls around. Now fasting
Ramadan is obligatory upon everyone who
is able. So what happened to that verse
that came before?
Was it mens? Was it abregated? Not
entirely. Listen to what Ib
says about that previous verse.
He says,
Yes.
for
[Silence]
mossina.
Oh. Here
I have actually a spelling error.
You have there.
Yes.
Is incorrect. The lambi
is
he touches him.
So it should be
it there's no such thing as
he says
he says this previous verse verse 184
and upon those who are able to fast but
fail to do so
the expeation of feeding a poor person
for each day that they miss. Iban Abbass
says this verse is not completely
abregated.
It is still
relevant to an old man or an old woman.
They find it difficult to fast and so
they feed a poor person for every day
that they miss.
[Silence]
And so here he says they are unable to
fast due to their old age. When we say
fast, we're not speaking about
physically fasting. We're speaking about
normal fasting
without
hardship. Okay? So, they instead
feed a poor person for each day that
they miss. This is the ruling for the
old man and the old woman. Now, is this
absolute?
No.
Let's say a person is getting up there
in age and some days he's able and some
days he's not, right?
He decides, look, I'm going to try to
fast and I'll start my day out fasting,
but if things get real tough, I'll break
my fast. Otherwise, I'll keep my fast.
They're free to do so. It's not you're
either fasting the whole month or you're
not fasting at all. No, there can be a
level of a level of you know trial
and error because a lot of people they
they don't want to break their fast if
they're unable to. But generally
speaking, a person who is old in age and
for the most part will have difficulty
fasting, this person is allowed to break
his fast. This person is allowed to
break her fast and to feed a poor person
for each day that they miss.
[Silence]
So we say that old age is not illness,
right? It's not an illness but it runs
in the same vein
as illness menration, postpartum,
breastfeeding, traveling. Right? So it
runs in the same vein. Therefore it has
the same rulings. Correct? Now we said
that there are two types of
illnesses, two types of people that are
ill with respect to the the time frame.
We said what are those two types?
Temporary and and permanent or chronic
or right musmin.
Right? So old age is more similar to
which of those two types of illness?
Musmin. You're not going to get younger.
Right? Therefore, it will take the same
ruling as a person who is chronically
ill. This is why they feed a poor person
for each day that they miss. Are we
starting to to visualize
how each of the pieces fit together
perfectly? We have a general ruling and
then we build on it. We have a general
ruling, then we build on it. It's not
just random
rulings. They're all based on
something, right? They're based on a
principle. We've set up about three or
four principles and now we are building
on those principles. Every year we have
questions. The same questions come up.
person is old, a person is
breastfeeding, a person is We are now
starting to be able to visualize these
things a lot better because we're
learning the principles upon which these
rulings are based. We know now why
an old person is able to break their
fast, why a breastfeeding woman is able
to break their fast. And we now know
their recourse. Why? because we were
able to base these rulings on a common
ground, a common foundation.
This is what FIK is. That's what it is.
Just random rulings.
You can't keep them all straight and you
will end up shooting yourself in the
foot. In order to properly understand,
it has to come from the foundations up.
Now
[Arabic recitation]